it is now four days since the supreme
court overruled roe v wade there has
been a flurry of commentary you may
recall that my show had already aired by
the time the decision came down on
friday i was on an airplane i rushed to
the studio right after i landed and gave
my breakdown of the ruling i certainly
was not the only one
there has been
a flurry of commentary around the
decision
but in a matter of just a few days i
have found it i have found
the single worst reaction to the supreme
court's decision in dobbs to overrule
roe v wade brought to you by cnn's anna
navarro
and because i have a family with a lot
of special needs kids i have a brother
who's 57 and has the mental and motor
skills of a one-year-old and i know what
that means financially emotionally
physically for a family and i know not
all families can do it and i have a step
granddaughter who was born with a down
syndrome and you know what it is very
difficult in florida to get services it
is not as easy as it sounds on paper and
i've got another another step grandson
who is a very autistic who has autism
and it is incredible and their mothers
and people who are in that society who
are in that community will tell you that
they've considered suicide because
that's how difficult it is to get help
because that's how lonely they could go
because they can't get other jobs
because they have financial issues
because the care that they're able to
give their other children
suffers
the supreme court's ruling is bad you
see according to anna navarro because
now it won't be as easy to kill people
with mental disabilities and she's not
even speaking in the abstract she's
speaking of her own family she's saying
you know i have this brother who's got
mental disabilities i have uh step
grandchildren with mental disabilities
and
and they're alive and that's horrible
it's so annoying that they're if they
were dead our lives would be so much
better that's what she's saying
congratulations anna you managed to beat
out joe biden and aoc and a whole host
of other contenders whose opinions were
also ignorant and evil but not quite so
obviously so that anna navarro reaction
is so
hideous it's
it's one of the worst
things i've ever heard in political
commentary
not just that
we should we should kill certain people
but we should kill extremely vulnerable
people not just that we should kill
extremely vulnerable people we should
kill extremely vulnerable members of our
own family because sometimes they might
seem a little inconvenient to us
her opinion is not an outlier it's not
unique
the left has been talking about this for
years they just usually have the sense
to speak a little more euphemistically
than anna navero is fortunately because
she's not as intelligent as the rest of
the left she says the quiet part out
loud but iceland was bragging about this
a few years ago there was a big headline
out of iceland breaking iceland
eradicates down syndrome there's no cure
to down syndrome they didn't eradicate
it in the sense of curing people who
have it they just now kill every single
person just about who has down syndrome
in iceland so they can say it's erratic
it's eradicated because you're
committing genocide that right that's
that's the eradication not something
exactly that you should be proud of
and you see it of course you see it when
you go into a doctor's office
when
a woman becomes pregnant you go see the
obstetrician
you will
be asked if you want to have certain
genetic tests and you say why would we
have these tests done
they say well look the tests are done so
that you can find out any abnormalities
if anything might be wrong you're going
to test for down syndrome and then we
can figure out how to proceed
what do you what are we going to figure
out well you know then we'll just kind
of make a decision on how you what
decision you want him oh you're asking
me if i want to kill my kid because he's
[ __ ] that's what you're saying
you're saying we're going to do a test
and we're going to find out if the kid
is [ __ ] and then we're going to
suggest that you kill him
and you know the craziest part
is it's it's more politically incorrect
it is more socially unacceptable to say
the word [ __ ] than it is to kill a
[ __ ] person killing a [ __ ]
person totally fine
totally encouraged promoted they're
whining on cnn because you're not
allowed to do it
but you can't say the word
don't you no you have to watch your
language while you're killing people
does that make a lot of sense i don't
think so joe biden is saying practically
the same thing not with regard to people
who have mental disabilities but with
regard to the poor he tweeted out quote
the cruel truth is that overturning roe
will hit poor women and girls the
hardest
that's the cruel truth what is cruel
about that
oh that you're saying it is cruel
that now
we won't be able to kill the poor
poor women
women who don't have a lot of money
now will find it a little bit more
difficult in certain states to kill
their children and this is really cruel
and terrible because now we're gonna
have more poor people and we're gonna
have to deal with them and isn't that
isn't that annoying
yeah i mean this is jonathan swift level
stuff this is eat the irish babies
because we don't want them around kind
of stuff
it's not coming even from some lunatic
on cnn that's coming from the president
of the united states
the takes on on the roe over ruling have
been from the left have been
almost uniformly evil but when they're
not evil they are extremely stupid and
this is where we have to turn to aoc aoc
says that the supreme court
sending the issue of abortion back to
the states and the people and the
people's representatives
represents a crisis of
democracy
what i believe that the president and
the democratic party needs to come to
terms with is that this is not just a
crisis of roe this is a crisis of our
democracy the supreme court has
dramatically
overreached its authority
we had
two conservative senators in the united
states senate senator manchin and
senator collins come out with a very
explosive allegation that these that
several supreme court justices misled
them in their during their confirmation
hearings and in the lead-up to their
confirmation this is a crisis of
legitimacy we have a supreme court
justice whose wife participated in
january 6 and who used his seat to vote
against providing documents that
potentially led to evidence of such to
congrat to investigators in congress
this is a crisis of legitimacy and
president biden must address that
absolute crisis of legitimacy crisis of
democracy what's the crisis
what's the crisis aoc at the end there
you hear she's going after clarence
thomas and his wife ginny which the libs
have been doing for decades because
ginny is a conservative political
activist and so they find and they've
been going after clarence thomas since
before he was confirmed
the larger claim that they're making
here is that the conservative justices
misled people and this therefore creates
a great crisis for our democracy
the dobbs decision
is very possibly the most pro-democracy
decision that we have ever had in the
history of the court the dobbs decision
represents one branch of government the
judiciary
giving away an issue
sending an issue back to where it had
existed for all of american history
until 1973 namely to the legislatures to
the democracy
it's a crisis of democracy how is it a
crisis of democracy when the people get
more of a say on an on a political issue
that of course is not a crisis of
democracy that that's an expansion of
democracy but it just reminds you that
when the libs talk about democracy they
don't really mean democracy this is how
it can be the case that when
more people vote for donald trump than
vote for hillary clinton
in the states where it matters where the
electoral college plays a role also in
this election
where the where the democratic process
favors donald trump over hillary clinton
that's a crisis of democracy
how
he won the people yeah but
but we didn't get the outcome we wanted
when more people in hungary vote for the
right-wing candidate victor orban then
vote for the left-wing candidate that's
a crisis of democracy democracies in
peril
how's that that's not that's just
manifestly absurd well it's the case
because when they say democracy they
don't mean democracy they mean
liberalism they mean leftism they mean
progressivism they mean whatever policy
agenda they want they can't lose
legitimately so whenever they do lose it
has to be a crisis of
legitimacy because for the progressive
left progress is clear they're on the
right side of history the arc of history
bends toward aoc or whatever and so when
whenever anything interrupts that that
march toward utopia that march
inevitably toward progress then it has
to be
it has to be a stolen election it has to
be the russians interfering it has to be
hanging chads in florida it has to be it
has to be anything other than what it
obviously is
in this case and and beyond which is
that the people don't exactly like what
the libs are doing right now go to
ring.com knowles it's summer and people
are traveling you know i've been on the
road for the past week i was in la santa
barbara i was in chicago i was all over
the place okay
and when i'm on the road i can feel safe
because of a ring you know you know ring
you're gonna say ring the video doorbell
company yes they have an amazing video
doorbell where you can see and speak to
whoever is at your door wherever you are
in the house outside the house wherever
you know they've got an alarm so they've
got ring alarm that protects your doors
and your windows and your whole physical
home from freeze fire flood and the bad
guys
now you got to go pro be like me okay
become a pro cnet calls ring alarm pro a
giant leap for home security
it is this amazing award-winning alarm
that protects not just your physical
home but your digital home too it
protects everything whether you're in
the home whether you're away from the
home you're just gonna feel safe the
cost is unbelievably low compared to the
other guys
you may not have known it but it is true
ring has that award-winning alarm this
busy summer season to protect all of our
homes you got to go pro with ring alarm
pro go to ring.com knowles ring.com
knowles
i'm so glad you liked that clip now
you got to subscribe you got a ring you
got to get those notifications this has
been the absolute greatest month for the
judiciary for the constitution for
american politics in a very very long
time make sure you get the notifications
don't miss a thing we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]